do you think you can teach someone to be
a great singer or is it just something
that either you have or you don't it's a
gift
and to hear notes like you know as far
as like pitch
right definitely I'm a Believer I have
to be I'm a far better singer at 41 than
I was at 19. my range is better my tone
is better everything why is better is
that because they're far easier for me
to sing now it's just you it's a muscle
right and it's in it and it's if you
don't use it you lose it right so it's
like I saw Tony Bennett like once like
years ago we were both this benefit and
I felt like I did a pretty good job on
stage and all the other singers did too
and then he got up there and I was like
I'm sorry what it was like eight or
something and I was like offended I was
like wait what and it was his voice
people think oh they're older they sound
different I think sometimes if you're
using it properly and you're constantly
working something and you're like I'm
constantly singing I'm constantly I'm
into it I'm writing I'm on the talk show
singing I'm doing stuff all the time I
think if you're constantly using your
gift and you're using it properly man
you can develop such a beautiful
roundness that you'd never have in your
youth or rarely do you have in your
Youth and and it just his voice he
sounded incredible and don't you think
like Billy Joel too like Billy Joel
sounds really good and I'm Amazed by
that yeah
I feel like is even better with age like
maybe Bruce Springsteen too I love Bruce
Springsteen I don't know if you know
this song but my favorite song is
actually one that he's not like singing
huge and big on I think it might be the
one song in his career he sang in like
falsetto the entire time and that like
high like sweet voice
um and I think it's called lift me up
but it's so good he he is underrated I
mean not underrated people think he's a
huge still obviously he's a huge star I
just mean he's underrated vocally I
think
um I don't think people give him enough
credit for being the just badass
vocalist he is
foreign